ALONG THE END WALL AND CAN I
SIDE FOR JOE AND AWAY
COMES JONATHAN HUBERDEAU TO
APPLY PRESSURE.
STRIPPED BY AND CAROMS TO  STAM.
STAMKOS'S PASS THE ROL.
WHEN HE LOSES CONTROL OF
OFF THE INTO THIS IS A GOOD FAC
SITUATION.
FLORIDA AT THE TIME SETS UP THE
SAME WAY. ME UP
AND DEFLECTED  THAT ONE.
COULDN'T GET THAT TO SAM BENNET
TO BARKOV.
EKBLAD
EKBLADHIGH ON FIRES A SHOT,
AND THAT SERGACHEV.
HE'LL DUMP IT IN ROSS COLTON TO
>> ANDREI VASILEVSKIY READ OF
THE PLAY MATCHES HIS ABILITY
WITH HIS LEGS AND HIS HANDND OW
BOTTOM OF THE SCREEN,  AND THIS
>> PUCK POSSESSION, USED THE
WIDTH OF THE ICE, WIN THE FACE
POKING THE PUCK IN THE
CORNER.
DUCLAIR BARKOV WITH THE ORIGINA
AND THE LIGHTNININTWO COACHES,
CUP WINNERS.
GREAT STUFF.
THE WHIST WILL IN THE BLUE
PAINT.
AWAY FROM
KATCHOUK AND RADDYSH.
KABLUE LINE PLAY.
YOU KNOT TO HAND IT TO HIM.
LUNDELL AND REINHART DOING A
FE
LIGHTNING.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE LIGHTNING DID ON SATURDAY
FOR THE CAPITALS, 4 FOR 4 BUT A
HIGH-PRESSURE SITUATION.
SURE,  AND THE
WHISTLE.
WHERE IS THAT THHE WILL BE OUT
FOR MOST OF THE DURATION.
I THINK HE NEEDS A LINE CHANGE
TURNOVER.
CAUSED THE